hello and welcome to playstation grenade
since
season five began i've received a ton of
myths from you guys to chase
so i've listed the 20 most requested and
we're gonna fly through those today
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes
slap code adamarrow in the store for
99 more dad jokes in 2021 enjoy your
christmas
and let's bust some myths
let's start with something christmassy
the snowmen returned to fortnite for the
holiday period
many people wanted to know what happens
when you jump into the zero point
dressed as a snowman the myth goes if
you jump through here will somehow
become snomando kinda like what happened
when john d
and his banana went through a rift well
there's only one way to find out
let's do this
okay not a big outcome the snowman
simply breaks on entry and the player
continues through the nexus
as normal i thought the next best thing
to do would be to throw a snowman
on top of the zero point but something
happened that i wasn't expecting
check this the item never technically
lands and instead
goes into this rotating falling motion
it's cool to look at but sadly this
is another busted myth we have loads of
zero point myths to cover in this
episode and here's another christmas one
what happens when a present is thrown
into the zero
point right away i'm thinking it will
act the same as the snowman did sort of
rotating and falling away
well technically i was right it actually
hits the zero point
and bounces off but something very
strange happened if it bounces far
enough away from the orb it will
actually reappear
on top of the sphere for a split second
there you go
it's beautiful my discard and i spent
three hours trying different myths in
private matches
and we found one that's quite
interesting check this myth if a player
jumps through the zero point with a
clinger attached they will not be
harmed this has to be too good to be
true
right well we tested it we chose the
victim and attached explosives
and to our surprise it's true the zero
point negates the effect of the clinger
and removes it from the character they
don't take damage whilst inside the
spear
so if you ever get hit with a clinger
quickly builds all the way up to the
zero point
and jump through easy claps
[Music]
okay let's break from zero point myths
for a while here's the next one
the npcs and io troops have secret
unreleased gliders
well how could i resist this myth the
community found a rift fish
and overwhelmed mando allowing me to get
close enough to rift him away
i accidentally took half the lobby with
me but we certainly got the mandalorian
in the air
and after a little floating around we
saw his glider
and well it's only the default glider
rip the dream
we tested this on other npcs and i o
troops too and sadly
it looks like all npcs have the default
glider and nothing secretive at all
something interesting did happen during
these tests depending on where the
mandalorian
is when we rift him he will always go
back to the original crash site
he always goes back home i thought that
was a little cool touch
our next myth asks if we can cancel the
i o troops elevator from rising out of
the ground by simply landing on them
first
sounds like a plan batman and another
super easy one to test
we dived straight down in a squad game
and landed where we knew an elevator was
to our surprise that lift function still
works and bounces us all
into the air the only problem you've got
now is that you're trapped with no
weapons
around the aimbot io commandos
[Music]
another regular myth i'm asked is
regarding npcs for higher and if they
will use the zero point and regain
health
you'd think this would be easy to test
right simply hire an npc and then build
up to the zero point and jump in
well it can be a little bit more
difficult as the npcs
aren't the brightest in the world and
sometimes they'll jump off the ramp
sometimes they'll turn back round and
run back down again
in the end we made a bridge and shot it
out just underneath the npc to test this
and voila myth chased npcs can indeed
use a zero point
and are healed too which is useful i
guess
this next myth is brilliant who will win
in a fight between
mando and the io troops this is the
perfect amount of epic
right now in game mando can spawn a
little further west than the colosseum
and if you're lucky enough the io troops
can spawn at risky reels
getting them together is a pain in the
butt the plan was to aggro mando and
then move slightly out of sight so he
slowly followed behind me
i did this all the way until reaching
risky reels where i then aggro the i o
troops too
then my job was simple it was to stay
out of sight until they forgot about me
and started to engage each other and
then suddenly it happened
the io troops moved upstairs to have the
high ground advantage over mando
but then committed a rookie mistake by
leaving that high ground
and being caught in a doorway face to
face with the mandalorian and his best
car steel
armor mando is tough to beat monoa mono
and after a spirited performance io was
defeated
impressive work from the mandalorian so
if anyone asks who's stronger a unit of
io commandos or dinjarin
you now know
next myth back to the zero point if a
knocked player enters the zero point
they will be revived this sounds epic
like usual the discord fan came to help
me and here's what actually happens
the knocked player lands on the zero
point but to our surprise
nothing else they stay on top they can
crawl around to their heart's content
it's super strange isn't it well here's
something even stranger
if another person uses the zero point
whilst that knocked player is on top
this happens they begin to fall through
the sphere but the animation
doesn't complete they glitch around
within the sphere until they are spat
away from the orb
and smash into a thousand pieces we
appreciate your sacrifice
we also tried this whilst carrying a
knocked player and the same thing
happens the zero point does not open and
we are left standing on top
admiring the view so another busted myth
here's a perfectly strange myth a shark
can travel through the zero
point what you're thinking there's not a
chance is there
we know that cars and other vehicles
can't travel through the orb
yet we know items like the klinger
grenades can
so let's try this this myth was so tough
to do
firstly there's not that many sharks
around anymore and they don't seem to
like fall damage very much
but that's not the hard part the real
issue was getting the shark to the top
of the ramp
the shark naturally loses speed going up
the ramp so to boost this we reattach
the line
this works but the shark always bites
down the moment the fishing line
connects
and this led to so many times the ramp
breaking underneath us
but you don't want to see our struggles
do you you just want to cut to the end i
understand
as the shark reaches the zero point it
completely stops
it's mesmerized by the bright twinkly
lights what do you think it's thinking
i reckon it's saying dude i love
fortnite
to make it move again we actually have
to reattach the line one more time
this time as the shark moves into the
orb it automatically deflects around the
side
and falls to the ground the person being
carried though can still enter the zero
point
and for a short time the fishing line to
the shark will stay
in place but ultimately it'll snap this
shows us the shark is effectively
another vehicle
oh yeah in fact there is another myth
here what happens when a plane goes
through the zero point
nothing it hits it just like the other
vehicles and throws out the passengers
inside
and finally what happens when a junk
rift hits the zero point
i thought this was going to be another
epic gamer moment but
this actually happens the rift travels
through the orb without
any reaction and crushes everyone on the
ground underneath still looks pretty
cool though
i tried this with a porter fortress 2
and although the item bounced away from
the orb
it did build over the zero point again i
was impressed but then
realized this was due to the ramp i used
to climb up and by knocking down that
ramp
it also made the zero point fort fall
too
oh we need one more number 20 the dragon
breath
shotgun can light campfires did you know
i have no idea why this is a thing but
it is incendiary so it does make sense
so hopefully that's useful to someone
and now i'm thinking about trying this
with the sniper rifle version 2.
so there we have it 20 myths in super
quick time
thanks to everyone who watches these
videos and takes part in these meetups
on my discord
and a huge thank you to those kind
enough to use code adamaru in the store
on screen now are more legends who rock
my code thank you for choosing me
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure have a good christmas
see you next time